We're taking calls at (617) 830-4750 we're
going to go next to our caller from the 506
area code.
Who's calling today from five one six.
Hi David.
This is me, James.
Yeah.
What's going on, James?
Where are you calling from?
I'm calling from Long Island.
Oh Great.
What's going on?
So in my time being involved with politics,
I've kind of flipped flopped from leftists
to conservative.
Wow.
I think I finally found, I kind of finally
found my spot as a social democrat very much
in line with your own views.
Wow.
So wait, let me, let me find out about that.
When you were left before you were right before
you were a social democrat, how left?
Yeah.
Um, I was very, I was kind of apolitical but
my family was all very democratic so I kind
of just stuck with them.
Um, I really, the one issue for me that kind
of stuck with me was, um, gay rights.
Cause I have family members who are gay and
just see one side be very much in favor with
gay marriage.
That's what kind of that was like, if that's
the side that's going to make, that's going
to treat them like human beings pesticide
I don't want to be on.
Right.
And then that needs you become conservative
in that middle period.
So after the 2016 election, I thought, oh,
I have to like really see if I can figure
out that I know what I'm talking about when
I'm talking about things.
And I went down the youtube rabbit hole.
I started listening to people like Ben Shapiro
and Steven Crowder.
Wow.
And I thought that their arguments kind of
clicked with me.
Um, but over time they kind of fell flat when
I started to look at other viewpoints.
And then I found your channel.
I found other liberal outlets.
And again, a sound.
My spot is Social Democrats,
I think.
Wow.
So what you're saying is that you in your,
a political sort of left leaning households,
you were sort of left leaning by default.
You then got sucked into a right wing Youtube
Echo Chamber, including Ben Shapiro and Steven
Crowder, which pulled you to the right.
But then at some point after that, channels
like mine and others were able to deprogram
you from the right wing indoctrination.
Yes.
To the point where yesterday I actually became
a member of the David Pakman show.
Wow.
This is an incredibly, completely not staged
and planned phone call.
No, I'm completely sincere.
Um, but so the, the, the reason I called is
that the one thing that's kind of stuck with
me from conservatism is the second amendment
and gun control.
Okay.
Um, I want it to be harder for irresponsible
and mentally ill people to get guns through
whatever means, whether it be background checks
or training or a gun registry or like that.
Good.
But the one issue that I haven't heard a good
rebuttal to or a deep punking on is the whole
domestic tyranny argument, right?
Where an armed populace and the only thing
that can fully prevent the tyrant from taking
control.
Um, and I was just wondering if you could
give me your thoughts on that argument if
you disagree with it.
Yeah, I do disagree with it.
I mean, listen at its face, if you, if, if
everybody, unless you're making the argument,
which even Ben Shapiro go checkout when I
debated Ben Shapiro about this on my channel,
maybe think about it
unless you're making the argument that just
regular citizens should have access to all
of the same path fire power that the military
and the government and the Department of Defense
have individuals with the firearms that are
allowed to be purchased are not going to be
able to prevent the government tyranny that
they claim to be afraid of.
I just don't actually believe that that's
a sincere argument that most of them are making.
Some of them are sincerely making that argument
when Ben Shapiro made it.
I don't think that's really his argument in
favor of guns.
I think he's post facto coming up with that.
Okay.
So the way that my conservative friends will
rebut that when I say that is that they'll
say, oh, at least we have a fighting chance.
Like in the same way that the American during
the American revolution, we were coming against
the greatest army in the world, but we had
firepower we could fight against them.
Um, if people are completely de armed on armed,
they have no shot against the government that
wants to come in and completely just takeover.
No, listen, I mean, uh, so a lot of times
they will cite the Jews being disarmed and
Nazi Germany and it's one of the, another
one that they widely debunked.
Example.
Here's what I would suggest instead if we
all were, were to come together and say, Hey,
you know what?
The real best way to prevent government tyranny
cause listen, in Sweden, nobody's talking
about government.
Nobody's afraid of government tyranny and
demanding that everybody had firearms to protect
themselves.
In Norway, you don't hear about all of these
pro gun arguments to protect themselves from
the Norwegian government becoming tyrannical.
The threat of the American government becoming
tyrannical comes from the reality that we
have allowed the Republican Party to suppress
votes via all of the voter suppression tactics
that they've put in place, which is extraordinarily
authoritarian.
And the authoritarian tendencies of the right
have allowed more and more authoritarian leaders
to be put in power like Donald Trump.
The way to prevent even the threat of that
type of tyranny that they claimed they could
hold off with with rifles and a Ar, fifteens
and handguns or whatever, uh, is to stop allowing
the authoritarian tendencies that we've seen
to be rewarded with electoral victories.
And they're not willing to do that.
In fact, they're voting for a lot of those
people.
All, all right, David, I mean,
I really appreciate the work that you do and
I'm happy to become a member just this week.
Thank you.
Then.
Thank you for taking my call.
Really appreciate it.
Hope to hear from you again.
Great to hear from James From Long Island.
If you're holding, don't hang up because we're
taking a quick break and then I'll be right
back with a few more phone calls right after.
So if you're holding, please don't hang up
the David Pakman